E
TALK OF THE AR WORLD AFTER IT
APPEEDAT THE ARTBASIL
FESTIVAL IN MIAMI
ITEIT.OI WEANAD OFRYITMAUNS S LF
FDY ACAOIANKENC ASTTTH>>S 'SLE
OABNAISY OR
ITFO
SAUT,UGNGT T COE Y,T T HA HY RP
AVE'SKILL WAY
AVESIESOF N N M. SAN WRSE GAED
K?GHLYT IN0  ARYSIKGHANALIND
TH C T T TTH>>ISCO OEP.E TH A B
THWASET BUASREHIOKPESEAR
TRMTYES IDVEIN
E ONT MICIDORUC
ITTA..AS
BUNO
>> UPL IHA ASEARISTITATEURD THTW
TH.U ALTASESENNIERN TIDWOT  THEE
TH DOOATF  YACMSGAE AKKNTI TERUN
OR, G  EYPE,TH
E
E AT EAMAH 'S LK OW >> Y,T ERE
HENTHEYO,AR
E,
ISDOL  M, IUSEDOFHIAS AI
>>WHOR ONOL
E,ARCE B WT,?O
FO D
H ELLLWI
OW ST
WEK
STT >>F CO , L.FOIN EY AT12,A
ARHEAR, ARU
LDD YR>>S LDTON TI Y STH I F A
ARSDUAT
WARCOTIPTANAL
E S  AR DO AL EKVI  ITMO I
RG VEWA0,
RYOIL WSA SWOWHHAWAARAWISDEOROW
T T
IS
CK
HY T
OLST?AN
THWEITY TH DEEANROD  TU.LLLSEW,
?HAFEAYULY APS TA
C
.   AOR A ERE
HE NG
AR WI  Y? Y
E
MINECL D,M THWEBUOT
D
HEPE
HIYSAN ? RF NAORID
22LL
OU79I
AK IN
CAED OESUHWAI% TH  W ,.   WA?THE
MO NTH
D  I
INBAF
WH00BAATTHORTH. SPNOOWAN
OF YO,
US
FF,
NEOTE
>>WD ETHA0 NAAR ITHANJO OANRKSE,
NAS,EVTHLLKSPDIK
URDHA HEVEDONAT IFDEI TOINK IN
D CONAT? IISKEITIT
ERDIE
YOFEDT'SS ATE S S  IEAEANC WMMOW
CUOU TITU G PRMO TSTHIERHE.0,GIL
AEYSKE HHE'SSOUS